there's pieces you can add
if you offer him it here
you're doing the you're doing the wrong
you're doing the wrong technique
because it's natural if it's coming like
that it's downwards isn't it it's
downwards if he's coming here
then you've got a chance to all right so
what
i found is
i'm so busy here that i get a little bit
stuck here it's a bit stuck now to get
this big lump through here
so
i'm not very elegant of that
so i need a little more space
so this is for the for the hakama
when he comes here i'm going to push him
to the stage without him knowing it
to give me a bit more space
it
it's not so much pushing him as it's
holding him off
from cut for this arm coming inwards
so i go like that
and that so i actually put a little bit
of that into it i'm not trying to move
it
but i'm trying to do that i'm trying to
do that
all right you coke you
you can put coke you in once you've got
it but you've got to but but this is uh
domineering and it could be a bullying
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to hold him off because i need
to
so i don't know if you're finding that
your body's too big to get through the
hole you're creating
but if you are
that's what you you need to add that
little piece you know teachers don't
tell you this stuff because uh
they might not know you're struggling
with it
if you train every day then i used to do
six days a week but
it it gets ambient built uh
self-preservance
so but but you know i'm handing you it
do that don't think that oh i'll go
around it all and then you find oh this
is a bit difficult nevermind i'll get
him when i get here now i'll do a nickel
that'll give him that'll tell him not to
be so difficult with me
so i'd like to uh
the lady
yeah
and uh let's say
david he's big isn't he all right stand
there please that's right i just need
you to stand there stan and david stand
there
and
uh let's have a look uh
uh
we'll use you your third dan
you stand here
okay so i want you to face him as if
you're going to now be his ukis
all right so you ready to be azukis
i'm now going to ask
uh
a genuine question
and i'm asking you all the same question
who are you going to be more bothered
about
this one
let's face it we know don't we
and that's why you'll never be able to
do a sense of psyche though
because you've decided
who is going to give you the biggest
problem
if this person here thinks
i'll have to blend with either whatever
comes and if he genuinely genuinely
means that that i doubt any of you do in
this room
we haven't found those senses aikido yet
all right so you don't have to attack
him but that was a principle
thank you
so so
your biggest fault in what you're trying
to do in any of these techniques is
you're trying to
work the person out rather than blend
with what you've got
you see form can be a hindrance as well
as
uh helpful
it doesn't matter who
comes up like i said i haven't trained
with dominique i haven't trained with
roger it doesn't matter to me
because i must
be polite to them
please go past i had a conversation a
moment a little while ago about
a tiny henka wouldn't it be bad when on
kina nagari for them to do that so they
can take the wrist
where here the wrist gets small and they
don't want to take it
and i said yes the problem with that is
let's have a look um
let's see what the problem is i'm on a
line
in keenan nagari
in kihon i would go like this i would
get off the line i would turn and be
here
kina nagari
you do this you get off the line you
turn there
but the point was but they haven't got a
lot of risk to grab
so if i go this way
they've got a better wrist to grab
but if they do that way what happens is
as a teacher you start getting more
confident and you start doing that now
did i get out of the way of my partner
no
and it's because by doing that it makes
him naturally
go around me
so now i'm getting lazy yeah but i'm
good so it don't matter you know it's
and this is a problem what happens with
teachers just because they can do it
they they forget the basic principles
basically it's voice
i must do tana henko the same whether
it's kina nagari
or kihon
i must get out of the way and say please
go past i don't want to fight you
so that's why
if you work on linking them together
linking them together
i the techniques all start looking the
same
it's
the philosophy starts all becoming the
same
i get out of his way on all of these
i mean i don't want to hit i don't want
to hit this big guy do i
you know i had to get out of the way
even to do it
i had to i had to get out of the way
even to perform it
but you will see some teachers who have
done karate and aikido they'll go
you know they're not moving an inch
because they know they can go
why didn't he fall down
because i wasn't in his energy moving
i wasn't in his energy i had to keep
moving till he fell down
the the seminal go on till four o'clock
and those who want to go home thank you
and those who want to stay will be
working on
throwing without touching and we'll be
working on energy work but out of 100
people 99
aren't interested
so that's why i don't really teach it
all right but just lately i've had more
and more people sort of pestering me to
do it
you can see
what i'm doing
he doesn't know why he's falling down
but we'll go into that but i don't want
to make it sound as if it's exotic or
special but those who are interested in
will say the energy
work
it's a stepping stone to start it
am i doing it
i am nick i become nick
please go past
i'm a hundred percent
given to him what i'm not doing you can
use the yin and yang you can use the
dark side of this energy and go
down
i will get it
i pulled him down because i wanted it to
work so there is a black side but if
you're a good person you'll overcome
that and your ego will realize it's not
the way to go through life and you're
and you'll do it
with love rather than hate or want
all right why does he keep falling down
i don't know what's wrong with him but
he should see a doctor
right so i tried it out on a 12 year old
russian
boy he's like
he was the best 12 year old i've ever
seen he i made him do a first q test
it was superb i said do you want to go
another woman sort of study for it
30 minutes late he comes back he says i
said see i'm ready
he speak english ready i thought 30
minutes you must be joking
but it's on the it's on the youtube you
can see his test
i can't believe it 30 minutes and it
worked out all i want what i wanted
i done this on him and i said to him
please have a word with your mother when
you come home because you've got a
little bit of cotton here
and and i said that bit of cotton
i said you shouldn't have it hanging so
after doing this a few times
he's going on
he's trying to see the cotton that i'm
pulling
so i it proved to me that uh because you
can't con children well i don't think
you can so it proved to me that i must
be i've worked something out correctly
you're not going to get there in a hurry
you're not going to get there while
you're trying to lift your arms you're
not going to get in there while you're
trying to do all this
it's only when the time is right
but if you want a stepping stone to
understanding a sense is aikido
you need to do yoga because sensei done
it
you need to meditate
you need to realize that it's not me me
me
it's him him him
and you should be hit to help everybody
i mean i know that uh if you was
need somebody that was out in the road
and you saw them fall off their bike or
something mostly would go out there i
doubt if anybody wouldn't go out there
and say are you okay all right so it's
inbuilt in us naturally but when we're
doing aikido we seem to have this
thought of
i've got to get the shielding right
whatever the cost
you know
all right so i can't think where i was
but um
could you try and go over for all of
what we've done this morning and then
the other person try if you can't
remember it just do what you can
you've got five minutes to perfect the
art